ANKUR KOTWAL: Thank you, Kunal.
Hi everyone.
I'm Ankur Kotwal.
I'm a developer advocate on the
developer products group team.
And today what I want
to talk to you about
is the 3Cs framework that
Kunal just introduced.
We feel that the
3Cs framework helps
to categorize a range
of technical challenges
that you will find
in this market.
And what I want
to share with you
are ways that you can
address those challenges.
So let's start off by
talking about connectivity.
The first thing to keep in
mind is that not all networks
are the same.
You can have users
on a 4G network
that have 2G-like speeds.
You can have users that
are on broadband networks,
on Wi-Fi networks, that
also have very slow speeds.
And in fact, that same
user on a 4G network
with 2G-like connectivity can
travel two blocks that way
and suddenly get
4G connectivity.
So what you want to do
is not make an assumption
about the quality of the network
based on its network type.
But you want to be continually
conscious of the quality
of the network that your
app is experiencing.
So to keep our apps
responsive and useful,
we want to do things like
prioritize our data requests.
Pull down text from
your servers first.
Because you can present that
information to your users
and have your app usable whilst
the rest of your images load.
To show you an example, you
can see here, with this app,
the text loaded
up nice and early.
And the images started
to load up over time.
We didn't fetch all the
images ahead of time, either.
So as we scrolled down the list,
we pulled more images down.
In fact, if you start
to think about it,
you realize that, as you start
to address unreliable networks,
you start thinking
more towards, well,
how is my offline experience?
Because they are, in
some ways, similar.
What we want to start to do
is actually optimize our apps
for useful offline experiences.
We want to start caching our
data where it's appropriate.
So when we fetch an
image from our servers,
we want to store that locally.
And next time, when we
need to present that image,
we want to present it
from our local cache.
There are libraries that
can help you with this.
Picasso and Glide-- these
are open-source libraries.
And I recommend
that you use them.
Because they will
fetch your URLs.
They will also cache it.
They will manage it for you.
And actually, they can help
you downsample those images.
And we'll talk about
that in a minute.
The material design
guidelines actually
recommend that when you
have space for images
and they haven't loaded
yet, you shouldn't leave
that with just empty space.
You should use flat colors
as placeholder images.
And we have a library called
Palette in the Android Design
Support Library that helps you
generate those colors depending
on the imagery
that you're seeing.
Now, this app here is
working in airplane mode.
And as you may have noticed,
as we scrolled through the app,
it was totally usable.
And that's because it was
designed with offline in mind.
So I recommend that you
look at your own apps
and see how they work offline.
And the way that you can do this
is just to go to your device,
put it in airplane
mode, and test it out.
It's a fairly
straightforward way.
And you may be surprised
at the results.
So that's a little bit
about connectivity.
Let's talk about compatibility.
One of the strengths of
the Android ecosystem
is that developers and users
have a choice of device.
Some users like small screens.
Some users like big screens.
Some users like great cameras.
Other users like more storage.
So this means that,
as developers, we
shouldn't make assumptions.
Or rather, we should optimize
our apps to be flexible.
I'm going to talk about that.
Let's start with screen sizes.
All of our layouts
should be declared
in density-independent
pixels, or DIPs.
Developers will
know these as DIPs.
A density-independent pixel
is basically a physical size
for your layouts.
So if you have a
64 by 64 DIP image,
that image is
physically going to be
the same size on a three-inch
phone or a five-inch phone.
And that helps our apps
be responsive and scale
to different device sizes.
Google also provides the
AppCompat and Design Support
libraries that include a set
of pre-defined components
that you can use.
These components actually
embrace the material design
guidelines that Francis
mentioned earlier.
But best of all,
these components
are backward-compatible
to Android 2.1.
So if you have users
on older devices,
on older versions
of Android, they
can still have a modern user
experience, a modern look
and feel, from your app today.
In India, everyone speaks
so many different languages.
You can go to one state and have
a different set of languages
to another state.
And so it's really important
that, as developers and content
creators, we create
content in languages
that our users
understand and can read.
To help with this effort,
Google provides the Noto font
that includes support for 10
Indic languages and growing.
And the great thing
about this font
is it's designed to
read really well.
But it's also designed
to scale really well.
It's really readable on a watch.
It's just as legible on a phone.
And it scales beautifully
to big screens as well.
As we go to build our layouts,
we also want to test them out.
So in Android Studio,
you can actually
preview all screen sizes.
So as you code your
layouts, you can
see how that layout looks in
real time on a set of devices.
And in fact, Francis
mentioned earlier
that we've recently
announced Android Studio 2.0.
It has a brand new emulator.
Now, I know many developers
have given us feedback
about our emulator before.
So I'm really
excited to tell you
that our new emulators are
faster than physical devices.
So when it comes to supporting
multiple screen sizes,
there's no excuse for having
a different set of emulator
configurations set up for
all the types of device sizes
you think your users have.
Instant Run makes
it even better.
Instant Run is a feature
of Android Studio which
will deploy changes that you
make to your code in just
a few seconds.
And the reason it
works so fast is
that rather than package up
your whole APK and deploy it,
it can connect to
the app that you're
debugging on an emulator
or a physical device
and just send the
changes across.
So it's really smart
and really, really fast.
It helps you make rapid
changes and see them
across various screen sizes.
But I want to switch gears
now and talk about memory.
Because memory is also
another differentiating factor
across devices.
And as developers, we should
be conscious of how much memory
is available to our
app at run time.
We have APIs like
isLowRamDevice, getMemoryClass.
And these APIs help give us
indications of how much memory
we have to play with.
So it's really important that
we actually request these values
and change our
behavior accordingly.
As we run on different
size devices,
we should also be conscious
of the images that we use.
Because we know that
images typically
take up the most amount of
memory in a running app.
So there's no point rendering
a really high-resolution image
onto a small little image
view on a three-inch screen.
You should be
downsampling that image
and presenting it
in the resolution
that you're going to show it at.
And again, Picasso and
Glide help with this.
They will not only
downsample an image for you.
They will cache
that as well, so you
don't have to keep doing it.
We love services.
Developers love services.
Because with services, we get to
do some work in the background.
We can preempt what the user
might want in the morning,
fetch some data,
do some processing.
But it's really important
that our services are not
long-running.
You don't need a service
that stays awake and active
the whole time.
It's actually much better
to have your service
wake up at appropriate times,
do its work, and then shut down.
Because then your
app isn't basically
running the whole time.
If every app on your device
had a service that was active,
there would be no memory left
for the actual foreground app.
And of course, in
the Settings app
you can check out what apps
are causing memory pressure
on your device.
And I really hope that your
app isn't one of those.
We've tried to be really
clever about giving you
the right tools in Android
Studio to detect memory usage.
So I want to call out
these two graphs here.
On this side, we have
a 512 meg RAM device.
And on the left side, we
have a 1 gig RAM device.
And what I want
you to focus on are
those numbers on the top left.
On the 512 meg RAM
device, this app
is using about 12
megs of memory.
On this device, the
same app is actually
using 36 megabytes
of memory, which
means that this app
is being really clever
and using all these
optimizations to adjust
its memory usage based
on what's available.
The other thing that
this tool helps us with
is detect things
like memory leaks.
You can see our graphs go flat
towards the end there, which
basically means our app is
allocating a bunch of memory
to start with, and
then capping it off.
We don't have leaks where
this graph just grows
and grows and grows.
This is the shape of a
graph that we should all
aspire to in our apps.
Battery is near and dear
to everyone's heart.
We love our devices so
much that we're always
complaining that we
don't have enough juice.
We don't have enough
batteries available to do
all the things that we want.
And so it's made
even worse when you
have apps that don't address
battery use appropriately.
So in your own apps, what
you should be doing is,
if you need to do some
background work, coalesce it.
Batch it up.
Don't have the device wake up
frequently for you to do work.
You're better off waking up
once, doing a chunk of work,
and then letting the device
go back into standby.
Even better, what
we should be doing
is making sure that we're
not running this sort of work
when the device is
running on battery.
We actually should
be making sure
that the device is connected
to a power charger that
is connected to a
network that's unmetered,
so we're not costing
the user money.
And there is an API to do this.
In Android Lollipop, we
introduced the JobScheduler
API, which does exactly that.
You can mandate heuristics that
say, I want to be charging.
I want to be on Wi-Fi.
And I want to do it around
this time of the day.
But I know what you're saying.
I don't want to just
run on Lollipop.
I want to support all my users.
The GcmNetworkManager API is
part of Google Play Services.
And it is JobScheduler
for Android 2.3
and up-- for Gingerbread and up.
Don't be fooled by the fact that
it's called GcmNetworkManager.
This is not a
GoogleCloudMessaging API.
It literally is for
scheduling your jobs.
And my personal favorite thing
is that both of these APIs
help you survive reboots.
So you can schedule a task.
And if the user
reboots their device,
or they turn off their device,
when they turn it back on,
you can dictate that those
scheduled tasks will still
run without you having
to re-schedule them.
So this is a great way to
respect the user's battery.
We've talked about
caching quite a lot.
But it's really important
that we don't just
run away with our cache.
We don't grow forever.
We do it intelligently.
So we should have a
strategy for caching.
We should hold onto the things
that are most important,
as well as the things that
are most frequently used.
Things that are
old and out of date
we should actually throw away.
Now, the nice way and
the easy way to do this
is to use Glide or Picasso
that manage this for you
for your image cache.
But if you're using your
own cache, something custom,
you definitely need
a strategy in place
that helps you manage it.
And the reason
that you need it is
because of this scary
notification-- storage
space running out.
You may have seen this yourself,
that apps have taken up
enough memory, enough
storage space, on your device
that your device is starting
to run low on space.
So what do you do?
You tap the notification.
And you see this dialogue.
This is the Settings app.
It sorts all the apps
by the amount of space
that they're taking up.
Now if your device
is low on storage,
and you can't take photos
of your family and friends,
the first thing
you're going to do
is start to uninstall
the big, heavy apps.
You really don't want your
app to be one of these.
You want to have a good
caching strategy in mind.
But I'm going to
give you another tip.
The Android framework
actually sends out a broadcast
before it gives the
user that notification.
That broadcast is
ACTION_DEVICE_STORAGE_LOW.
And what you can do is
listen for that broadcast.
And at the point
that you receive it,
you can clear out your cache.
And that means you're doing
exactly what the system wants
you to do.
The system is saying, hey, look.
I'm running out of storage.
Can you please
clean yourself up?
And you're doing that.
You're clearing out your cache.
And better yet, you're trying
to remove your app from being
at the top of this list.
So the apps that
don't respond to this
are more likely the ones
that get uninstalled.
You should go and measure
the storage of your own apps.
The Settings app does this.
In fact, it breaks
it down very nicely.
You can see how much space
your APK is taking up,
how much data in
the data directory,
as well as your cache.
So go ahead and measure it.
Look at your storage space
across different devices.
All right, connectivity,
compatibility--
let's talk about data cost.
The first cost that your
users incur from your app
is actually at installation.
And we know from research
that Indian users
are sensitive to APK sizes.
And they're not just
sensitive to the APK size
when they install the app.
They're just as sensitive
to it when they upgrade
to a new version of
your app and are alarmed
by just how big it's gotten.
So the first thing you
should do is audit your APKs.
If you feel like your APK
size is starting to bloat,
make sure you don't have
really high-resolution images
in your app that are targeting
low-resolution devices.
You should profile your users.
Use the Play Developer Console
to see what type of devices
are installing your app.
And if you find that you
still need those assets,
you should consider
using multi-APK.
Multi-APK is a configuration
in build.gradle.
And the reason it's useful is
that if you think about how
APKs are built today,
when you hit Build,
we compile one
monolithic APK that's
applicable to all these
different densities, right?
Multi-APK helps you
split up your APK
so that you end up with an
APK for LDPI, MDPI, HDPI,
so on and so forth.
So it's a really simple
build configuration.
It adds a little bit
of overhead for you.
Because when you upload
it to the Play Store,
you have a number of
APKs now that you upload.
But the benefits
are huge, right?
Because you end up
with an APK size
which is much smaller and really
targeted to your user's device.
It helps you get
those conversions.
And you can track the growth
of your APK size on your
build server.
We've talked about
data at rest-- caching.
Let's talk about data
in motion-- things
that we request over a network.
We really should be efficient.
And there are many ways
we can be efficient.
A simple way is we
only request the things
that are visible on screen.
So we saw an animated
image earlier of an app.
Those images were
being pulled down
because they were
being displayed.
We weren't trying to
pre-fetch ahead of time tons
and tons of images.
We were being clever about it.
In terms of efficiency,
we also never want
to request the same
image from the network
if we don't have to.
So the first time you
request it, you pull it down.
You cache it.
The next time you
need it, you'll
get it from the local cache.
It's really, really
important we do these things.
We also want to
optimize our images.
We want our servers
to send us images
that are downsampled already.
You don't want to have to
fetch a high-resolution image
from your server and
downsample it locally.
Because that's
cost to your user.
You've transferred
all those bytes.
There's a file format that
can help you called WebP.
Now, I know what
you're thinking.
Did he say WebP?
I thought it's an Android talk.
WebP is not just for the web.
WebP is a file format
that's very much
relevant to mobile apps.
In fact, Android has had support
for WebP since Jelly Bean.
And WebP results in a smaller
file size than PNG or JPG
at both lossy and lossless.
So it's something you
really should consider.
Now when it comes to
measuring our data use,
Android Studio provides
an excellent monitor.
This is the Network
Monitor on Android Studio.
And you'll see here that
our app is requesting
three short bursts
of data, and then
big ones-- big, chunky requests.
This is the type of data
request that you should have.
There on the left,
those initial ones,
we requested the text that we
were displaying to the users.
Then we started to
pull down our images.
So go ahead and monitor
and measure your own apps.
See how they fit in with this.
So that's just a taste
of what's possible.
India is an exciting place.
The number of users coming
online are exciting.
The opportunity is
immense and huge.
So I hope today that, by
sharing with you the 3C
framework and some ways
that you can really
optimize your apps
for India, you're
able to be the apps that
these new users want and love.
With that, I'd like to
invite Bapu Kota, the CTO
and VP of Dailyhunt, to
talk about their experience
with applying this framework.
[APPLAUSE]
BAPU KOTA: Hi everyone.
I'm Bapu.
I head engineering
for Dailyhunt.
I wanted to start off talking
about the spread of literacy
in India, the spread of
local dialects in India.
So as we know, India
is a diverse country.
It has 22 official
languages and off the census
reported literacy of 70%.
Only 10% makes up for English.
What that amounts to is
that, like Kunal said,
around half a billion
mobile smartphone users
consuming internet
services would
be engaging with these services
through local language.
This is our playing field.
Dailyhunt is India's largest
news and content platform--
content ranging from ebooks to
content helping with education
and test prep material.
And these stats help us.
So far the app has
been able to manage
over 110 million installs.
Through the
high-engaging experience,
it manages 3-plus billion
page views a month,
over 28 million book downloads.
And then the last statistic
is very important.
And that highlights the
nature of consumption--
the consumption pattern both
in terms of users and usage
on our app.
So we see that more than
95% of our usage and users
look to consume content and
services in local languages.
At Dailyhunt, we are aspiring
to be a destination that offers
daily habits for our users.
We wish to be the first point of
internet access for the users.
And towards that, we've
been investing heavily
in terms of not just
building for scale
on the back-end-- building
services and platforms that
are able to manage this
larger scale in terms of reach
and engagement-- but also
equally emphasizing on,
like Ankur was detailing just
now, aspects around experience
and aspects around performance.
I just wanted to walk you
through a couple of things
that were relevant given the
flow of our session so far.
On the localization and script
support, we have within the app
a rendering engine that is
built on top of Android's
native TTF-based rendering.
And this helps us transform,
compose, and render content
from across 15 Indian local
languages based on 12 scripts.
While we look to
transfer the content
from our back-end systems
onto the app on the front end,
we also do certain kinds
of compacting and backing
that helps us optimize the
size of the content that
transfers from the
back-end infrastructure
to the front end.
This eventually shows up
in terms of better user
performance on the app.
Since we are local
language-focused,
we also invested in tools that
help a nontechnical workforce
in helping us build an
experience that is also
localized-- not
just the content,
but also the navigation and
the entire user experience.
So we have tools that
allow people to contribute
towards translation, people to
contribute towards corrections.
And then the tools take care
of building those translations
into the APKs that eventually
the users get to use.
We are also very
focused on managing
the performance of our apps
on low-bandwidth networks,
and put a great emphasis
on testing and validating
our experiences on
low-end devices.
We believe that if
we focus on creating
optimal performance of the
app on lower-end devices,
then with better capabilities
and resources on the devices,
the app's performance
will only be more optimal.
Some of the things
that we've looked to do
and that have helped
us include things
like having different
HTTP engines for text
versus images versus ads.
I think Ankur just walked
through this one as well.
On the images side, we
have benefited tremendously
by shifting from other formats
of images to WebP-based images.
And this has given us savings
from anywhere between 30%
to 80%.
We also do
bucketizing of images.
Because on the news
side, we have experiences
focusing on news aggregation,
news curation, and news
personalization.
Our back-end systems
create buckets of images
as they acquire content
from publishing houses.
And these buckets of images get
mapped depending on the device
resolutions that the users own.
And this has helped us in
managing an optimal experience
in terms of not just the size,
but also the way in which
the app renders itself.
As far as the images go,
one of the other things
that we have looked to do is to
manage a prioritization policy.
So the images follow a
last-in, first-out order
wherein the images on
the screen take priority.
And therefore, the overall
experience on the user's side
ends up being more responsive.
So that's pretty
much what I wanted
to cover in terms of
some of the things
that we've attempted to do,
much along the lines of what
we have heard through
the other sessions.
We have benefited.
We have continued to invest
in making our app better.
We are launching features
like offline mode,
doing better at caching,
and then allowing
the user to engage with
the app and consume content
in the offline mode.
So thank you.
We look forward to having
you try out the app
and help us with your
valuable feedback.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right,
thank you very much.
I hope you can see why it's
really important for you
to optimize your apps for India.
With this, I'd like to now
welcome back Kunal Soni.